here's a sentence I thought I'd never
say president Trump postpones a trip to
Denmark because the Prime Minister won't
sell him Greenland I'm also not going to
Denmark same reason but I'm okay about
it and so should you
I mean it's Denmark a rainy little
monarchy made up of a hundred islands
some of which are barely inhabited I
know because I read Wikipedia the go-to
source for any boring filler about
Denmark but really canceling a meeting
with Denmark is like blowing off lunch
with that third cousin who wears a
monocle and waxes his moustache but
let's be real whether it's Greenland
Omar or sleepy Joe all you're watching
is a show those people are just comic
sidekicks they're the Gomer piles of
modern politics Trump's turned his
presidency into his dream job a talk
show on wheels and he's done it without
having to spring for the budget plus he
lives in his own green room and wherever
he goes the media follows like groupies
schlepping the gear and if the
helicopters nearby Trump can offer an
opinion which fuels the next episode
even posing a question about Denmark's
ice cube becomes Story fodder it's
genius and then there's this tweet from
Trump and X John classic effectively
this is not just a presidency it's the
Truman Show redone as the Trump show
which is good because Trump's way
funnier than Jim Carrey the danger is
following the media's lead and getting
obsessed by this to them it's the game
of Trump and they're binging on it
reacting to every new plot twist and
that's just not healthy
instead sit back enjoy the show it's all
in good fun until of course someone
loses an eye land started with Island
and worked backwards see what you did
there yes I'm ashamed of it Dana I think
I think Denmark is playing hard to get
they want to attract the highest bid
this is what you do blame I like art of
the deal it's like art of the deal they
are playing it they read they clearly
read tobacco got it out of the deal yes
I always wanted to go to Denmark never
been I would like to I would like to
visit I have to remember in all of these
things the Prime Minister she has
politics too yes right so she has to
deal with her press that isn't the same
as ours also the president didn't really
expect this thing to leak yeah this is
apparently and I thought they were
talking about the selling like he was
making a serious bid he's like well what
could
possibilities and then it leaks and all
of a sudden now we're in a fight with
Denmark okay you wanted siscon Katie
this is kind of why I like Trump in the
sense that he asks questions that I
would ask like who has anybody on the
moon yeah like he's a businessman
everything's for sale we do yeah exactly
could I buy Easter Island I bet I could
yeah everything you tell Trump is a
consideration yes right like he'll talk
about it openly and be like oh yeah
that's something that we can talk about
or consider and they talk about it any
changes his mind because he'll talk to
anyone about anything yes I am still on
team manifest destiny in Greenland for
lots of reasons
everyone says that global warming is
causing things to melt more advantages
for tourism right but let the
Greenlandic people decide if they want
to be part of America or Denmark put it
to a vote they can decide and then on a
serious note in 10 years the media is
gonna be saying what are we doing about
the Chinese in Greenland because they
want to mine in Greenland they already
wanted to put a bunch of airports in
Greenland China is on a hundred year
plan Trump is on a six year plan that
will extend to you know the history of
the country and that's something that we
should be thinking about because China
is already there and we're playing the
short game and they're playing the long
game what are we gonna do about Africa
Brazil Oh green New Deal it's a little
easier easier destiny Greenland's a
little more I was I was struck though
that he the way he does diplomacy he
calls her nasty he's got a lot of people
nasty oh I know that pathetic me anyway
I think you know this was an absurdity I
thought this was a joke but remember he
confirms the joke if it was just a
matter of our private discussions
between his advisers why did he have to
come out and say oh yeah I know I really
think this is an idea and I here's the
historical background it was an absurd
preposterous idea right and then he says
oh why are you calling it an absurd
preposterous idea the problems with him
not with the people in Denmark not with
the people in Greenland this guy he's
won know so far China's not
you want your having after is you're
having a mental breakdown it's fun no
you think it's the foreman show that's
what you said right well it's true money
to match the groom and also bid on it
yes Roman sure would be like this guy
supposed to be the president on every
single United States the president would
acquire Greenland if they had the chance
to pass US presidents tried to acquire
Greenland that's not absurd and he
didn't make a rude and nasty statement
when he floated this idea it floated
he's open to it and Lisa could it's a
conversation flowed and you know what
who was nasty the Danish leader was
nasty or all she had to say was you know
what we love Greenland too and I
appreciate the fact that the president
United States also has loving feelings
towards this part of the world maybe we
can discuss it when we have this meeting
which I expect will go great and we can
solidify US Danish relationships
that's all she had to do but she rudely
dismiss it as absurd so he can't so they
you know what if I were her I would use
it to extract concessions from the
United States of a we don't have to do
our NATO exactly because they're under
budget on their NATO dues by a cup-like
billions of dollars so all she has to do
is string Trump you know maybe the rest
of it may grant adjust him and get what
yes you know what their people in
Greenland you know what she said you
can't buy people so if Putin comes over
and says hey United States I saw your
present I'm driving up to Russia you say
is a huge threat but the acquisition of
Greenland would deter Russia yeah maybe
you're not really serious about fighting
should be either the next ambassador to
Greenland or maybe the governor of
Greene we're trying to get me out of
here solution thank you
we should consider all options and buy
as many interesting things as we can
agree like Greenland awfully yeah like
Saturn Saturn why not Saturn okay far
far away